Why the Inside of Apples Turn Brown When Exposed
to Air
If you’ve ever wondered why the inside of
apples turn brown when exposed to air, well,
wonder no more.
The insides of apples turn brown when exposed
to air thanks to a built in defense mechanism
against bacteria and fungus.
The trigger for this is damage to the cells,
such as when you cut the apple, which then
results in certain enzymes within the cells
being exposed to oxygen.
When this happens, the enzymes react to the
oxygen creating an oxidized layer that provides
some protection against foreign bodies.
More technically, an enzyme called polyphenol
oxidase (also known as tyrosinase), which
is comprised of monophenol oxidase and catechol
oxidase enzymes, when exposed to oxygen will
result in phenolic compounds in the apple
tissue turning into ortho-quinones or “o-quinones.”
O-quinones are what is providing the protection
from bacteria and fungi as they form a natural
antiseptic.
The o-quinones themselves have no color, but
they further react with amino acids and oxygen
to produce melanin, which is how we get the
brown color on the cut cells of the apple.
If you want to keep cut open apples from going
brown quickly as they do when just sitting
on the kitchen counter, simply place them
in a refrigerator.
This will drastically slow the chemical reactions
and thus the oxidation process.
You can also, of course, limit the apple’s
exposure to air via sealing it in an airtight
bag or jar.
Another option here is to put the cut apple
in water for a similar effect.
If you don’t mind a lemony flavor, spray
the exposed area in pineapple or lemon juice.
This will stop the polyphenol oxidase from
reacting to oxygen thanks primarily to the
acidity of the juices which denature the browning
enzymes.
(This also works with avocados, potatoes,
etc. for the same reason.)
If you don’t like the taste of lemons, a
similar method involves rubbing the surface
of the apple in salt, sugar, or some form
of syrup.
Yet another method of stopping the browning
process is to heat the apple to extreme levels,
which if the temperature is high enough is
another way to denature the polyphenol oxidase.
This is commonly done when making things like
apple pie by dropping the apples in boiling
water and leaving them there for a few minutes.
Bonus Facts:
• Cocoa, tea, apple juice, and coffee are
all varying levels of brown for the exact
same reason a freshly cut apple’s pulp turns
brown- polyphenol oxidase.
Polyphenol oxidase also is needed in the browning
of humans, once again involved in the process
of creating melanin.